Okay.
Next question, David.
Will the 2020 election lead to violence in
the streets?
That could be interpreted a bunch of different
ways.
If your question is violence by whom, I guess
is the question right, there could be violence
in the streets if Trump wins and there could
be violence in the streets if Trump doesn't
win and the violence in either or both cases
would be by different people.
I mean, I guess let's, let's just sort of
go through it because this is so often asked
if Donald Trump wins, uh, will there be violence
from leftists in the streets?
I think it is very unlikely.
I mean, okay, we cover left wing violence
to the extent that it exists.
Most of the political violence in the United
States violence over politics is right wing.
We did a story earlier this week about it.
Will there be violence in the streets if Trump
wins from Trumpists celebrating?
Uh, I don't know.
Uh, probably not.
I don't, I don't, I don't think so.
I think the most likely source of violence
electorally would be if Donald Trump loses
and Jens up, uh, anger among his base over
a so-called fraudulent election.
I think that's the most likely scenario to
lead to violence in the streets.
Um, and I hope it doesn't happen and I think
it's really important.
You know, when we talk in the lead up to an
election about we want the highest voter turnout
possible.
Part of that is the more people are engaged
with the democratic process, the more difficult
it is to sort of fire people up along the
basis of these fraud claims.
If everybody knows they voted.
And, uh, there, there is sort of an easy way
to corroborate that the results that we've
seen are the results that people believe are
the correct ones.
It makes it much more difficult for authoritarian
leaning folks like Donald Trump to actually
fire people up and, and uh, in more significant
ways.
I think it's also important when we talk about
securing the election, um, to understand that
on the back end, one of the negative impact
of not securing the election can be more of
an opening for violence in the streets.
The, the, the likes of which I'm being asked
about here.
So when we talk about voter suppression, when
we talk about foreign interference, when we
talk about all of these things, the more secure
we all believe our elections to be, the less
likely it is that there is going to be that
sort of violence.
If, and I hope it really doesn't happen, Donald
Trump loses in November of 2020 but claims
that he was robbed in some fraudulent way
and his supporters grow up, go crazy and get
out on the streets, some portion of them will
take the bait from him and we'll do it.
But if the majority of the country, if a plurality
of the country understands that no, we have
a democratic process and it worked reasonably
well, uh, there is no cause for violence here.
That is a great insulator from that type of
violence.
I hope that there will not be violence in
the streets.
And if there is, I know we have the resources
to quell it responsibly and respectfully.
People who are just exercising or right to
speech should not be manhandled.
There shouldn't be violence done against them
by law enforcement.
That's extraordinarily important to remember
as well.
Uh, but those who are violent on the streets
do need to, uh, suffer the consequences of
that because we should be against all of those
forms of violence.
No question whatsoever.
I want to hear from you about it.
What do you think is the most likely scenario
to lead to violence in the streets?
I think again, the most likely scenario is
violence from the right over Donald Trump
losing and claiming that he didn't, and saying
that he needs some kind of support in staying
in the White House, which I do not believe
he would ultimately be able to do.
Let me know what you think.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.